in 1819
american author washington irving
published a short story about a man
named rip van winkle in the story rip
lived in a sleepy village in the
catskill mountains of new york where he
spent his days hanging around the local
tavern the king george and avoiding his
wife anytime she asked him to do some
work on their farm one evening rip was
walking in the mountains when he came
upon a strange group of men who gave him
some liquor to drink he fell asleep and
when he woke up the next morning he went
back into town and found that everything
had changed instead of a sleepy village
there was a bustling town and the
inhabitants all seemed to be loudly
debating over an election one person
wanted to know if rip favored the
federalists or the republicans groups
that he'd never heard of the king george
tavern had transformed into something
called the general washington tavern and
outside it someone had put up an
unfamiliar flag bearing stars and
stripes gradually rip realized that he
had been asleep not just for one night
but for 20 years and that he had slept
through the entire american revolution
now this is just a story and it's a
pretty fun one i can't do it justice
here but i highly recommend you read it
but this story reveals a lot about how
americans thought about the amount of
social change that accompanied the
american revolution
if you like rip van winkle fell asleep
in the british colonies and woke up in
the united states which aspects of life
would be familiar to you and which would
be completely alien in other words how
much did the american revolution really
affect society if we set out to answer
this question as historians what we're
really doing is exercising the
historical thinking skill of continuity
and change
what changed and what stayed the same
from before the revolution to after it
we know that the revolution changed the
political status of the british colonies
in north america which went from being
part of the british empire to being an
independent nation but how big of a deal
was that really was it not much more
than erasing british colonies from the
map and writing in united states instead
or did it actually lead to far-reaching
changes in how people lived
if we're trying to answer this question
we really only have three options
first things changed a lot there was a
great deal of change and things were
very different after the revolution
compared to beforehand
second things didn't change much at all
the revolution was a revolution in name
only and most things were the same
afterwards or third some things changed
but other things stayed the same
when we're asking what changed and what
stayed the same over time we need to be
consistent about the aspects of society
that we choose so that we're comparing
apples to apples so let's decide which
aspects we're going to compare over time
there are a lot that we could choose
from religion
slavery
gender roles class and social structures
political institutions it's a little
like a choose your own adventure book
for historians all right i'm going to
choose
political institutions
social structures and gender roles why
am i choosing these well i guess that
i'm interested in how the ideas of the
revolution that all men are created
equal and that government should
represent the will of the people played
out in reality did the revolution really
lead to more equality for men or for
women did government really become more
democratic so let's pretend that we're
rip van winkle taking a gander at the
society around us before and after the
revolution i'm not going to go into a
whole lot of detail here but if there's
anything you're not familiar with just
jot it down and then you can look it up
when you have a chance so what were
political institutions social structures
and gender roles like before the
revolution well first of all there were
13 separate colonies not just one single
nation the colonies were ruled by a
hereditary monarch the king of england
and they had virtual representation in
parliament colonists considered
themselves englishmen who were entitled
to the rights of englishmen colonies had
property requirements and usually also
religious requirements for voters
economically things weren't too bad for
your average white colonist in the north
although by the eve of the revolution
there was a growing number of our people
as land became scarcer american
colonists were generally better off than
the working class back in britain in the
south however the planter aristocracy
ruled with a handful of wealthy white
slave owners dominating society and
politics white indentured servants still
existed in both the north and the south
although the practice was becoming a
little less common most african
americans accepting a few free people of
color in the north were enslaved and had
no hope of social mobility safe for
running away indigenous people were
taking advantage of the dueling empires
of britain and france as best they could
but after the seven years war the
departure of france meant that they were
dealing with britain alone the british
government tried to prevent more
conflict between white settlers and
indigenous people with the proclamation
of 1760
which stipulated that the colonists
could not expand west past the
appalachian mountains gender roles in
the american colonies mimicked those of
british society pretty closely white men
did farm labor women cared for the home
and children a woman had no political or
legal identity apart from her husband in
a practice called coverture so a married
woman couldn't own property or vote both
enslaved men
and enslaved women worked in the fields
all this history has tired me out let's
take a little rest and come back to our
chart in a minute
ah that was a nice snap hang on what
year is it did we sleep through the
whole american revolution yikes let's
finish this chart quickly how different
were political institutions social
structures and gender roles after the
revolution in terms of politics things
had changed instead of 13 separate
colonies ruled by a king in parliament
there was one nation ruled by a three
branch government where citizens were
directly represented in congress instead
of the rights of englishmen people
appealed to enlightenment ideas of
natural rights with protections from
government tyranny enshrined in a bill
of rights many states reduced or
eliminated property and religious
requirements for voting expanding the
electorate among white men overall
social structures were pretty similar
with the exception that the institution
of slavery was being phased out in
northern states and the indentured
servitude of whites was being phased out
pretty much everywhere in the south
slavery continued for indigenous people
american independence meant that that
proclamation line was no longer being
enforced and white settlers saw western
lands as one of the prizes of victory in
the revolution gender roles also looked
pretty similar to before the war
coverture remained and men and women
continued working at the same tasks that
they had prior to independence one minor
difference was the elevation in the
status of white women who earned respect
for their contributions to the war
effort as daughters of liberty after the
revolution they took up roles as
republican mothers who instilled civic
virtue in their sons and also required
more education in order to properly
inculcate those values so what do we
make of these changes and continuities
the biggest area of change was going
from hereditary monarchy to democracy
expanding the vote for white men the
ideas of liberty and equality had some
impact on social structures and gender
roles leading to the gradual abolition
of slavery in the north and some new
opportunities for women if i were to
answer our question with one of those
three options i'd say some things
changed and some things stayed the same
the revolution changed the rhetoric of
rights and expanded democracy for white
men but didn't have much of a positive
impact on the lives of women enslaved
people or indigenous people now you
could choose totally different aspects
of society to look at and come up with a
completely different take than me this
is what being a historian is all about
if we take care to select aspects of
society to compare across time we can
answer some tough questions about how
society changed sleep tight